WELL AS LISTS OF POLITICIANS AND
OTHER POLICY TARGETS.
KAUFMAN HAS BEEN IN JAIL SINCE
HIS ARREST.
>>> ONE YEAR AGO TOMORROW THE
U.S. CAPITOL POLICE FORCE WHICH
OF COURSE WAS ALREADY REELING
FROM THE EVENTS OF JANUARY 6th
SUFFERED ANOTHER TRAGIC LOSS.
AN INTRUDER RAMMED A PAIR OF
OFFICERS WITH HIS CAR AT A
CHECKPOINT GUARD THE ENTRANCE TO
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS.
ONE OF THE OFFICERS, AS YOU WILL
RECALL, DIED, BILLY EVANS, AN
18-YEAR VETERAN OF THE CAPITOL
POLICE AND A MEMBERS OF THE
FIRST RESPONDERS UNIT.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS SHOWED THEIR
GRATITUDE AND APPRECIATION BY
ALLOWING HIS BODY TO LAY IN
HONOR IN THE ROTUNDA OF THE
CAPITOL.
PRESIDENT BIDEN ATTENDED THAT
CEREMONY.
NOW A MEMORIAL PLAQUE IS BEING
PLACED AT THAT SECURITY
CHECKPOINT.
JOINING US NOW EXCLUSIVELY IS
BILLY EVANS' FORMER WIFE SHANNON
TERRANOVA.
SHANNON, I CAN'T EVEN THINK OF
THE UNIMAGINABLE LOSS.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME YOU'VE
SPOKEN PUBLICLY.
WE ALL KNOW ABOUT YOUR HUSBAND'S
HEROICS, ABOUT HIS SACRIFICE.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU WANT MEME TO
KNOW ABOUT BILLY?
>> FIRST, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
YOU KNOW, AS MANY PEOPLE HAVE
SAID, BILLY LOVED HIS JOB AND HE
WAS PROUD TO BE A CAPITOL POLICE
OFFICER.
THE BIGGEST THING FOR HIM WAS
BEING A DAD.
AND IT'S A TREMENDOUS LOSS AND
DIFFICULT FOR OUR CHILDREN TO
MOVE ON WITHOUT HIM.
AND I JUST KNOW THAT WHAT I WANT
EVERYBODY TO KNOW IS THAT HE WAS
A GREAT HUMAN BEING AND HE IS
VERY GREATLY MISSED, NOT JUST BY
MY CHILDREN AND I AND HIS MOTHER
AND SISTER, THEIR FAMILY, BUT
EVERYBODY AT CAPITOL POLICE.
>> YOU'RE COMING FORWARD NOW A
YEAR AFTER THIS TRAGEDY TO THANK
BILLY'S CO-WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES FOR WHAT THEY DID.
TELL US HOW THEY'VE BEEN PRESENT
FOR YOU AND YOUR KIDS OVER THE
PAST YEAR.
WE'RE SHOWING SOME OF THE
PHOTOGRAPHS YOU'VE SHARED WITH
US.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
RIGHT AFTER THIS HAPPENED, AND
WE WERE ALL IN SHOCK, TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO, YOU KNOW,
MOVE ON, WE HAD SOME OFFICERS
COME TO THE HOUSE AND BE A
DISTRACTION.
THEY BROUGHT SOME MOTORCYCLES
OVER.
>> WE'RE LOOKING AT PICTURES OF
YOUR BEAUTIFUL KIDS.
HE LOOKS LIKE A GREAT DAD, YOU
CAN TELL.
>> YES, HE ABSOLUTELY LOVED HIS
CHILDREN, HE WAS THE FUN DAD.
YOU KNOW, SOME OFFICERS CAME
OVER WITH MOTORCYCLE UNITS TO
DISTRACT THE KIDS THE WEEK AFTER
THE K9 UNIT CAME TO GIVE US TIME
AND KEEP THE KIDS DISTRACTED,
ESPECIALLY DURING THE FIRST
SEVERAL WEEKS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, IT DOESN'T STOP
THERE.
WE COULD NOT HAVE GOTTEN THROUGH
THIS YEAR WITHOUT THE NORTH
BARRICADE MEN, SERGEANT KING,
AND SO MANY OTHERS WHO WORKED
WITH BILLY AND LOVED BILLY, THEY
CAME TO BIRTHDAYS, THEY HELPED
CHRISTMAS, THE FIRST CHRISTMAS
WITHOUT THEIR DAD, BE SPECIAL,
HAVE MORE PRESENTS UNDER THE
TREE, SPOIL THEM THE WAY HE
WOULD HAVE.
FOR HIS BIRTHDAY, WHICH WAS JUST
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, A WHOLE
GROUP OF POLICE OFFICERS,
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICERS, GOT
TOGETHER, THEIR FAMILIES
TOGETHER, AND WE DID A BILLY
BOWL.
AND EVERYBODY DID THAT IN HONOR
OF HIS BIRTHDAY BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT HE WOULD DO WITH THE KIDS,
TAKE THEM BOWLING ON HIS
BIRTHDAY, THAT'S WHAT HE LOVED
DOING.
THEY'VE BEEN THERE TO HELP
SUPPORT ME AT A CUB SCOUT EVENT
WHEN I JUST COULD NOT MANAGE
JUGGLING EVERYTHING AND TRYING
TO BE AS PRESENT FOR MY CHILDREN
AS POSSIBLE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU'RE ALSO
GOING THROUGH GRIEF, AND THEY
ARE TOO, SO FOR ME IT'S NOT ONLY
THAT THEY SHOWED UP IN SO MANY
WAYS, BUT THEY'RE GRIEVING TOO.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY WERE ABLE
TO DO THAT.
AND I DO WANT TO MENTION MY KIDS
HAD THE BEST LAST DAY OF SCHOOL
PICKUP EVER, A WHOLE MOTORCADE
OF THEM CAME.
EVERYBODY FROM THE NORTH
BARRICADE CAME TO PICK THEM UP
ON THEIR LAST DAY OF SCHOOL AND
HAVE PIZZA WITH THEM THE WAY
THEIR DAD WOULD HAVE.
>> WE SHOULD NOTE THAT
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR AMY KLOBUCHAR
AND REPUBLICAN SENATOR ROY
BLOUNT SPONSORED A RESOLUTION TO
PLACE THE MEMORIAL PLAQUE TO
HONOR BILLY.
>> OUR FAMILY IS SO HONORED, AND
I KNOW BILLY'S FAMILY IS SO
HONORED, FOR THAT.
THE FEELINGS ARE STILL VERY RAW.
WE STILL FEEL LIKE SOMETIMES
IT'S VERY SURREAL, IT DOESN'T
FEEL LIKE THIS REALLY HAPPENED.
I JUST WANT TO THANK BOTH OF
THEM, SENATOR BLUNT AND SENATOR
KLOB
KLOBUCHAR, FOR MAKING SURE BILLY
IS NOT FORGOTTEN AND THAT HE IS
REMEMBERED, AND THAT HE IS
ACKNOWLEDGED, BECA